- [Adrian] I describe
it as having bubble gum,
and once it's lost all its
flavor, you have just a piece
of rubber that you chew
over and over again.
That is essentially
what food is like for me
when I put food into my mouth.
My name is Adrian Wellock,
and I have lost my sense of taste.
I suffered a cold,
and I started getting a
metallic taste in my mouth.
Once that finally left, took
my sense of taste with it.
It took me a few weeks
to actually identify
that it was my taste because
I could smell perfectly.
I only eat foods now which spend
very little time in the mouth.
Because I don't extract any flavor,
the idea of a chocolate bar or a steak,
the way you chew it in order
to bring out the juices
and the flavors of it,
there's no enjoyment from it.
So I find myself eating very light foods
like salads and rice.
And also, I use the
advantage of adding herbs
in order to make the smell
sensation quite enjoyable.
I also find the spice very important.
Spice is not actually something you taste.
It's something you feel.
It gives it that sort of tingle in my mouth.
You end up with a rather
peculiar eating pattern
that people look at you funny
because you're putting chilies
on your breakfast cereal
and you've put a mustard
sauce on pretty much a lot
of the food you eat.
And almost three years now,
we're still none of the wiser
as to why it's gone or getting
my sense of taste back.
(playful music)